everything with crypto bitcoin dogecoin
coinbase
has come to a screeching halt and has
gone down significantly since elon's
uh snl appearance he came on there and
since the opening monologue when his mom
showed up on mother's day
and he's like i got you something for
mother's day mom she goes please tell me
it's not dosh going it goes it's
dogecoin
yeah and then went on and on and on and
basically called it a
essentially a a scheme not not a scam a
scheme
a side hustle a hustle he's like oh it's
a hustle michael che asked him
yeah it's a hustle it's comforting right
i mean for the guy that's that
influential
just joke about it follow the money look
where it's gone
um so ever since his appearance uh it
has gone down so something that's also
come to the forefront
which i actually appreciate is like
things are coming out there the good the
bad the ugly everything
the negative the positive something that
doesn't necessarily coalesce with his
whole views on life and his business is
the amount of energy that it takes to
mine
bitcoin that's like the one big thing
that's coming out there it's like yeah
it's digital currency yeah
and it's built on the blockchain and all
these good things about it but it's like
yeah
do you realize how much energy it takes
it takes
i i showed you the bill mark can you
pull that up out there i mean how much
energy it takes to mine uh
it's crazy bill maher who is obviously
not a fan of crypto he came out against
it draws line in the sand and basically
said
this takes a [ __ ] load of energy so you
can't be
pro environment and pro bitcoin all in
the same
uh uniformity right there because it's
sort of
it's an oxymoron because it takes so
much energy
yet you know you if you're pro
environment and you know green new deal
and you're also cryptoed out it doesn't
necess uh
add up so here yeah you can't be more
contradictory than to have
a car company right to get away from
fossil fuels and then you're all into
this other thing that's why i think he's
effing with everybody
i really do i think this is sport for
him what does he have to lose he's worth
180 billion
this is fun how else is he gonna get any
fun he can't go anywhere he can't do
anything
he goes anywhere he gets mobbed right i
think this is his sport
something to keep in mind about elon
musk is if you go back
pre-pandemic even during like a year ago
from now do you know his net worth a
year ago
probably under a hundred oh dude it was
40. it was like 40 billion
and now he's at over 130 billion where
is he now i don't know his exact net
worth
but to go there's it that's a different
level before now he dropped
number four but the point is to go from
30 40 billion to 130 like the guys
added a 100 what's your point don't you
think your perspective
and and your maybe your god complex will
change a little bit when you have
another 100 billion to your net worth
don't you think things might change
just a little from your perspective i i
don't uh
i don't disagree i think there could be
something happening there you know the
other day i was tweeting about
how much it cost to make a penny it's
2.2 cents to make a penny right
i don't know if you know that's that it
cost 2.2 cents to make 200
2.06 to make a penny it makes no sense
it cost
uh the federal reserve five and a half
cents to produce every dollar bill
five and a half cents to produce every
dollar bill and here's the kicker
how many hands does a dollar bill or a
five dollar bill exchange in a year
let me say that one more time how many
hands what do you think the number one
dollar bill a thousand
a dollar or a five dollar bill i'm
actually curious to know what the
viewers will say how many hands do you
think a
dollar bill or a five dollar bill in a
year put me down for a thousand you
think a thousand people will touch the
dollar bill or five dollar bill what do
you think the number is
five thousand it's actually a really
interesting number it's 110
110 110 people it's it's i was waiting
well maybe your dollar went to too many
strip clubs so they changed way too many
but there's a lot of strip clubs there's
other body parts that that touch too
unfortunately
yeah but but i'm usually the rated r guy
you got a
two pg-13 guys going out so so i have
richard who they keep telling me that i
got to get this guy on
our heart who responds and says do you
know it costs 40
000 to mine a bitcoin i don't know if
it's true or not
he says can you type in how much does it
cost to mine a bitcoin
he says forty thousand dollars to minor
bitcoin if
if it costs forty thousand dollars to
mine a bitcoin are you
kidding me like so someone that's not
sustainable it's not sustainable
one more point about elon you know we
lump him into this category with the
one-dimensional nerds
billionaires the guys that have created
something and that they're hyper focused
on
technology or building a company like
that in my opinion i think elon is
65 business genius 35 entertainer
i really do he's his wife is or his mom
was a supermodel
you know on the cover of vogue you know
i think he is an entertainer almost as
much as he
is a business tycoon a tech genius etc
so some of this is sport for him
he gets more amusement out of this than
anybody else with a high net worth so i
just find
forbes article kai i don't know if
you're looking at the forbes article i
put okay
right there go right there it says pull
up and press control plus to make it
bigger so the audience can see it
and can we flip on the camera so the
audience can see it as well
okay if you go there and take a look it
says
in early 2020 researchers predicted the
cost to mine bitcoin will be
around can you get rid of that okay
we'll be around 12
to fifteen thousand dollars after the
block reward how howling in may
have like split split but it is now much
cheaper to mine bitcoin btc than the
initial estimates the low breakdown
price to mine bitcoin may leave its
vulnerable to correction
uh go go little lower i saw five to six
thousand dollars go a little lower see
what else we have on the bottom
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going okay
so so i you know again 12 to 50 right
there
we came on miners based on china said
that the breakdown break even cost to
mine bitcoin hovers around five to six
thousand dollars
the break even cost around five to six
thousand dollars considering the cost of
mine bitcoin for the big mining centers
individuals miners can range
five to eight thousand dollars miners
have more incentive to sell to cover
operational costs
rather than to hold on to the btc they
mine so five to
five to eighty five hundred dollars to
my bitcoin here's the kicker
he said forty thousand right let's say
he's right it used to be forty thousand
to mine a bitcoin
then it went down to twelve thousand
twelve to fifteen thousand dollars and
it goes to five to eighty five thousand
dollars
i think they're gonna find cheaper ways
to mine bitcoin long term regardless of
it that's pretty expensive
to mine a bitcoin what do you think
about that
i'm gonna ask a question that i i assume
half our audience is thinking
how the hell do you mine a bitcoin i get
it it's not mining like a gold digger
yeah
are you figuring out com computer
algorithms where'd you go
with the gold digger comment where are
we going with that it's awesome i'm just
gonna
but the one thing that i i actually
appreciate
if you guys haven't seen bill maher's
take on cryptocurrency it's actually
a pretty impressive one whether you
agree with him or don't disagree
actually he goes
i've read articles about about crypto
i've done research on bitcoin and i
don't understand it
and neither do you and especially when
it comes to mining
so unless you're living this kind of
life like my buddy adrian lives in this
world and i'm like how the bebop is
doing and the bitty bops and the
bitcoins and the bitty boos
people don't understand this i i know
many people have jumped in on the crypto
craze
and have no clue what they're doing by
the way i don't think you're wrong i
think a lot of people would agree with
you i think a lot of people are clueless
and they're acting like they know and
they simply have no clue what's going on
yeah
a lot of people are going to look like
idiots that are self-proclaimed experts
on this right now and are
so loud and so adamant about it because
there's a good chance that this whole
world changes in a few months when it
comes to crips you you underestimate the
power of idiots looking like geniuses
i mean you you you you have to realize
there's a lot of idiots in the world
that stuck around and they were patient
banking on what's going to happen long
term and next thing you know
they're living in that 10 million home
driving a nice car and 15 million in a
bank and you're asking how'd you make
your money
i simply went into doge i went into
crypto i went into bitcoin i went to
ethereum there are people like that out
there
there's something that's got to be said
though about putting in
actual work there's a lot of bitcoin
millionaires out there who
you know kudos to them i'm not talking
[ __ ] that
weren't working that hard and you know
heard you know they were dealing stuff
on the dark web and in the black markets
and they heard about this and they kind
of lucked out yeah with where bitcoin
goes
at the end of the day i think a lot of
people just don't want to work that hard
and they want to get crypto rich
and i think that's going to be very ugly
for a lot of people who just want to get
rich quick and don't want to put in the
work well you got crypto rich
no well your life is not how i got rich
no no no no no no no that's not how you
got rich i'm not saying that but you
experienced a moment of crypto rich in
the last 90 days yeah i did
kind of an interesting thing yeah your
account on your account yeah how much
it's a good amount of money right that
you're millions millions right and it's
like what the hell just happened yeah
now i owe money somehow
he's got to go mine it i just had five
million dollars in crypto
[Music]
i electricity in this nft platform
and i couldn't even spell nft at the
time but the guy's like oh it's a good
idea you got to do it but
so i think there's a lot of people look
at the end of the day with crypto you
can't
don't invest money you can't afford to
lose i think a lot of people want to get
rich quick
and they're in on this crypto scheme or
scam or or hustle whatever you want to
call it
or if it's legit whatever you want to
view it but this is not work
by the way shout out to chad williams
he's driving and listening to the
podcast had nice words to say
uh while he's listening to the podcast
chad appreciate the 50 bucks but i'm
gonna tell you guys a guy right here
just said something saying
ripple xrp is in a lawsuit with sec
could be the first crypto regulator 99
of cryptos will disappear
they are also in the crypto climate
accord so here's what it means if one of
them
gets regulated they can use the same
case
it is so important for the crypto
community to make sure
ripple wins it is just as important for
competitors to make sure
ripple wins as it is for them to because
if they lose
who they can go after how familiar are
you with this ripple xrp
as far as what just in general what what
it's what it is the business
i'm not so i have two different
perspectives here i have one friend
ricky spoke to him he's in australia the
criminal defense attorney this guy's
like the biggest
he is the biggest advocate for ripple
out there again he's an attorney he
doesn't he's not a crypto guy
um but all he talks you in on ripple yet
xrp and then i talked to my buddy adrian
who's like dude don't touch that with a
10-foot pole
it's outdated it's not gonna work it's
there's lawsuits
so again it comes down to perspective
who's right who's wrong i don't know
you know it remains to be seen but it's
speculative
it's not a translation adam hasn't made
any money on it yet
that's not true but that's tough you may
not trade 2200
in the last three years on crypto you
can't you can't that's real money right
there
okay so there's a couple zeros behind it
he's brewing
still haven't gotten go ahead oh there's
a six month lock up here that's whatever
that is yeah
six-month lock-up that sucks yeah well i
mean it is what it is so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you